oh it's
beautiful
i'm vengeance welcome to the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host definition
and i've probably watched the new batman
trailer 500 times
wha what what a loser however on my
469th watch
i noticed something that made me think
back to a happier time before the world
went to crap
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down how the trailer confirms
the second suit leaks that we had way
back in february
and also discussing what other cool
little details we've noticed in the
trailer
since giving up our life to it obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you want to go into the movie as
blind as a bat then i highly recommend
that you turn off now
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so this post was dropped on dce
leaks by
user throwaway all the way back in
february i'd pretty much forgotten about
this
and everything from the start of
lockdown however seeing this scene which
sets it up play out in the trailer
it brought it all flooding back like
like when you wake up next to a woman
named sharon that you pulled on a
weekend bender in liverpool
but you don't care about that so firstly
let's discuss the post in full
and then go into how we actually see
this play out for real
now the user stated we're currently
working at the codington sheds in
bedfordshire in shed one
we finished building a huge cathedral
setting there just a bit ago
and have begun filming inside so
recently mat reefs revealed the batsuit
we just started filming with it recently
it looks very cool in person
and robert looks great what i know from
filming in the current cathedral set
piece
is that the suit gets destroyed very
early on
i think it's due to a villain but i
couldn't tell it's batman's prototype
suit
and once it gets destroyed he makes a
new one i haven't seen it in action
but i saw a few pictures taken by
someone who's putting it together
it's extremely similar to the spider-man
shield suit from the far from home movie
last year
the material is very similar being a
sort of tactical padded fabric material
there's way less straps and extra
details on the batsuit compared to the
spiderman suit
but the material and look is very
similar it's grey with full black gloves
extending to his forearms
and black boots the symbol is no longer
metal and
lacking ears it's a more classic version
of the symbol
rather than the first suit in the film
the cowl is made of a higher quality
material than the leather of the first
cowl
the ears are medium to long length and
the mouth opening is much smaller
he no longer has a collar i think he
might have white eyes too
the utility belt is a bronze gold faded
color and it's more pouch than the
futuristic metal type belt of the nolan
films
if i had to describe the certain
pictures rather than words it would be
this
the batman will have multiple suits
throughout the film the user then posted
the following image
and yeah lots of things that we can take
from this now
we not only know that there's a scene in
a cathedral but we also know that the
suit gets destroyed
in the lead-up to dc fandom i'd heard
that with this funeral scene bruce was
there in regular clothes
the location then got stormed by a
villain in a large suv
bruce fled and returned in his costume
and this was then destroyed
i've actually reported on that a couple
of videos so go back and watch them you
schmuck
now in the trailer we see all this play
out and there's also a split second
where the man who's pretty much been
turned into his own riddle explodes
throwing the batman back clearly a lot
of damage is dealt out by this
as it sends him hurtling across the room
now to me
this confirms that there will be a
second suit in the film
considering the leaks were posted all
the way back on february the 18th
they got too much right including the
setting and explosion
to in my eyes be wrong i can see a lot
of people being kind of confused about
why the person on set
didn't really know which villain it was
but if you look at the scene itself
all that really is is the person and the
car itself
you can also see that guy's head coming
off now because of this you can see why
they would be confused over this
so it does add some legitimacy to the
leaks now as for the suit itself
i think it sounds absolutely amazing i
actually really like the one that
pattinson has
but i'm open to seeing what else they
can do with it it does look very sort of
prototypey
and it reminds me a lot of the arkham
origins one which
was of course upgraded for the character
further into his role as the dark knight
i think a darker more stealthier suit
makes a lot more sense
and it will allow batman to be more like
a ninja than this previous armor heavy
incarnation
now at the dc fandom panel matt reeves
himself said that the suit was going to
be constantly evolving
and it would grow just as much as batman
did from the aesthetic of this piece
even down to the bat cave you can tell
that this batman is just constantly
throwing things together
more than i do terrible rumors every
week however
this one looks like it's now confirmed
due to the fact that the suit gets
really badly messed up
and the scene is so close to the leaks
it is hard to deny that they're not one
in the same
even if the leaks aren't true and the
suit doesn't look like a stealth suit
i do think that batman will have to fix
this one up as it's gonna be so bad off
that explosion
it will be difficult to see really if
he's even able to salvage it
reeves did confirm that they've only
filmed 25 of the movie so far
so yeah you can expect some big change
ups going forward
now shout out to matthew james for
messaging me on facebook and actually
sending the screenshot that sent me
spiraling back down this rabbit hole
there's a
split split second in the trailer in
which batman gets shot
and you can see the symbol on his chest
light up almost like the old classic
yellow and black one
it's definitely a cool little easter egg
and who knows this might actually be the
second suit itself
it flies by very very briefly when you
watch it in real time
however it does seem similar to the
description
either way i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts on it so make sure you
comment below and let me know
now before we get into the rest of the
video i just want to let you know we're
giving away a free copy of marvel's
avengers to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with a
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the leaks in
the comment section below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of august and the game will be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay now as for the trailer
one of the coolest easter eggs i haven't
seen pointed out is that the design of
the riddler
looks like it might actually be based
off the zodiac the killer was at large
during the 70s
and he used to taunt the media by
sending them coded messages
something that we also see here this is
apparent in the way that the riddler
looks with his glasses and mask
and also the symbols that he leaves
behind on the clues
underneath his mask we can also spot
he's clearly wearing some sort of
forensic suit
to make sure that absolutely no trace of
him is left at any crime scene
now shout out to superhero nexus for
spotting that on the front of the clue
is an
owl this is linked back to the court of
owls who are big batman villains from
the new 52
their members are a part of gotham's
high society and they control almost
everything in the city from behind the
scenes
until batman brings them down dc is
actually giving them a lot of focus at
the moment
and they're also going to be featuring
in the upcoming gotham knights game
which 2 was announced at fandom
we also see the back of gordon's head
and the police officers around him
are looking past him likely at batman
the camera perspective here is from
batman's pov
oh my oh wait am i am i looking through
batman's am i
oh my god i'm batman anyway gordon also
says
this mean anything to you i kind of hope
the reply would be
doesn't look like anything to me which
would have been the best westworld
easter egg of all time
but we don't get it anyway the clue says
what does a liar do when he's dead
the answer is that he lies however the
symbols on the right
also link up to several letters in order
to spell this out
which further ties back to the zodiac
inspiration
we also see for a split second that the
back of catwoman's head
has the ears in the balaclava she's a
cat burglar and though she doesn't have
a suit yet
this is a really nice touch that i
didn't mention in my initial breakdown
there's also a split second where the
cowl is removed and
after watching the trailer i do think
this could link back to the suit being
destroyed
the logo also contains a very brief
moment where a question mark can be made
out too
now i have seen a number of theories
state that they think the villain is
actually hush
that might be the case as hush and the
riddler did work together in the graphic
novel hush
however the green coat tends to be
typical of the riddler's style
and also hush wasn't one to leave
riddles
whereas the riddler was also it looks at
one point like batman is gonna have a
fight with a policeman and he's saying
to gordon
hold me back mate hold me back swear me
life mate i'll knock him out
also not really an easter egg just matt
reeves owning
noobs saying that the music used is not
actually a cover song when people moaned
about it
it's not a cover song it's nirvana oh
yeah oh yeah the 10
are we at the 10 minute market what you
can just put adwords in eight minute
videos now
well why didn't you say so man i've been
dragging this out anyway obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the video
and the trailer so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you want to see our initial breakdown
then check it out after this
as we had a lot of fun with it i also do
a face reveal in it so yeah
i know you definitely you definitely
want to see that
just make sure you don't watch it around
your girlfriend now if you want to
support the channel and get to see
content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat us
on a discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thank you for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
definition
i'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
do